[Music]
the hierarchy in the dceu is about to
change all over again but how will James
Gunn's new Batman movie fix the Dark
Knight trilogy's biggest mistake after
months of speculation James Gunn has
announced a slew of new films and TV
shows that will steer the DC franchise
into the future they include a new
Superman movie A lanterns Series in the
style of True Detective and a Supergirl
project that promises a much harsher
depiction of the titular heroine however
bands of Gotham City's favorite
Crusaders will be more enticed by the
Brave and the Bold little is known about
the new Batman flick at this point in
time but we can take some educated
guesses based on the Nuggets of
information that have been provided for
one thing the film is reportedly
influenced by Grant Morrison's Batman
run Damien Wayne has also been confirmed
as one of the characters which suggests
that the AL ghoul family might make an
appearance and this is how the Brave and
the Bold could be the perfect
opportunity to write the only wrong and
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
many critics and fans agree that Nolan's
Dark Knight trilogy is the peak of comic
book Cinema the films have been praised
for their gritty and somewhat realistic
approach to superherocentric
storytelling boasting villains whose
acts of Terror are rooted in real world
fears let's put a smile on that face
unfortunately the films have also been
criticized for whitewashing certain
characters including Talia and Roz al
Ghul in simple terms whitewashing means
casting white actors and traditionally
non-white roles in the DC Comics Talia
al Ghul is of Arab and Chinese ethnicity
Roz also originated from East Asia in
the source material though some stories
imply that he's of Eastern Roman descent
comic books retcon characters all of the
time but Nolan was clearly inspired by
the Asian iteration of the al Ghul
patriarch in Batman Begins the eponymous
hero meets Roz in a bhutani prison and
later travels to Tibet to join his
League of Shadows organization where he
receives his martial arts training of
course Nolan's movies aren't the only
superhero projects to whitewash
characters of color but DC now has an
opportunity to change that Trend with
Damien Wayne set to play a big part in
the Brave and the Bold the filmmakers
have a chance to rectify the mistakes of
Nolan's al Ghul family in the grant
Morrison Comics that have apparently
influenced this project Damien is the
Son of Batman and Talia therefore it's
reasonable to assume that the all ghoul
Dynasty will inform the film's story to
some degree it's also possible that
they'll draw upon the version of Damien
from the Brave and the Bold animated
series which presents the youngster as
The Offspring of Bruce Wayne and Selena
Kyle however the Morrison connection
suggests that the filmmakers will opt
for the more interesting version of
Damien one who's the heir to both Wayne
Enterprises and the al Ghul Empire
luckily James Gunn has a history of May
making colorblind casting decisions some
of which have resulted in more diversity
and inclusion for example the high
evolutionary and Guardians of the Galaxy
volume 3 will be played by Chuck Woody
iwuji a British actor of Nigerian
descent the original comic book
iteration of the character is depicted
as a white gentleman from northern
England Gunn defended the decision as
having nothing to do with race noting on
Twitter that iwoji is the best actor
he's ever worked with it's probably fair
to say that the future of the dceu will
be diverse indeed albeit in unexpected
ways
foreign